ừ ừ
à à
anh alo
Ừ ok em
Xin
chào các bạn
chấp nhận là do là hôm thì chủ nhật mới
là chỉ nên là hôm nay mình vẫn cảm thấy
ra à
áo kiểu cách 1 ngày livestream một lần
công nhận là cũng dày đặc đúng ạ Không
biết các bạn thế nào nhưng mà có bạn thì
bảo với mình là hiểu giúp là bạn ấy đôi
khi cuối tuần mà mới rảnh thì bạn đấy
cậu cuối tuần mà phải xem một phát 3
video Rồi mỗi video phải hơn tiếng
nghe cũng khá là mệt nếu mà học dồn đấy
là không ổn lắm
à vì học lập trình của mình nên chải đều
nghĩa là thánh chỉ là nếu mà phù hợp
nhất thì nếu mà không kiểu Xem trực tiếp
được hết thì ạ Vẫn nên một ngày xem cách
ra bởi vì mình đã dạy cách rồi thì các
bạn xem cách hơn là kiểu một ngày dồn
hết vào trong 10 ngày cuối cùng cuối
tuần do mà ngồi xem hết thì
khó khó để mà làm được
À hôm nay ra ăn sớm như thế này nhưng mà
mình
mình có mỗi cái tâm sự hôm trước mình
nói lại mỗi một cái
em
nghe Bây giờ mình tranh thủ đang có ít
bạn ở đây mình xin cho hỏi trước thì hồi
trước là cái
mình mình trong nón mình từng tham gia
công ty cấp thì công ty cấp và từ hỏi
mình coi rất là hai cái câu họ có hỏi
khiến Kiều
ở chỗ dạng là thơm các bạn hai cái câu
này nghe nhạc trên mạng suốt rồi nhầm
như là
bạn phải luôn trả lời được rồi câu hỏi
đó là tôi là ai đúng các bạn nghe câu
nói về chị ạ
I và mục đích sống của tôi là gì với cậu
thế
Bây giờ thích thì các bạn có thể trả lời
trước là có người đi không ạ
bạn thử nghĩ xem trả lời được câu ấy giờ
gen liên quan đến triết học nhiều hơn đủ
chia ly thứ tôi là ai ngoạn mục đích
sống của tôi là gì
em đã từng có rất nhiều người trả lời
cái câu là cái câu tôi là ấy chỉ đứng
tên của họ
cái việc ví dụ Giả sử tôi là ai Tôi là
Nguyễn Nam Long thì nó trả nghĩa gì cả
thì thực sự người ta nghe những xăm gạo
chẳng biết đấy ai cả kêu cái thế đúng ạ
đề thi
thì các bạn sẽ phải trả lời cái câu tôi
là hay sao cho người ta hình dung được
ra con người bạn mặc câu đấy phải là một
câu nên là trong một câu thay vì câu quá
dài dòng
một câu kiểu
chi tiết
ờ ờ
có một cái câu kéo dạng là các bạn không
để liệt kê ra giả sử Tôi là Long tôi là
là kiểu
áo kiểu là lập trình viên Vân Vân các
thứ thứ đâu là con người hài hước hay
cái gì đó
Ừ nó nào giống như là kiểu trên tình đời
chẳng biết ở trên tin domain không giới
thiệu bản thân như thế nào trên đi đâu ở
thôi tôi giới thiệu bản thân bay bướm
kêu dạ thôi
copy mấy cái ở 22 hay đăng lên đấy ý cho
người ta nghĩ mình có vẻ hay hài hước
thì hãy
như đại Khánh Thế cái cái cái công ty đa
cấp đấy
Cho hỏi hỏi tôi câu đấy xấu rồi cùng thì
còn còn bảo là bây giờ các bạn thử viết
lại à à viết lại là mục đích sống của
bạn là gì ra xử là
là bây giờ bạn tưởng tượng là bạn à
Khi bạn mất đi thần tượng là bạn sẽ chết
thì thì người thân của bạn
sẽ cậu nói gì
có đền đám tang mạnh không mà phải 5tam
bạn sẽ nói gì này họ sẽ
họ sẽ nhiều gì nhất về bạn đấy
cái đấy nó sẽ trả lời rồi sau cái câu
tôi là ai cũng của của mấy ông
à
nghĩa làm chỉ là lúc lúc đấy Xong rồi họ
còn mở cái nhạc của Quà Tặng Cuộc Sống
như vậy áo phải Quà Tặng Cuộc Sống Nó là
kiểu đánh nhạc của Secret gardens nhớ
thế tôi mà em ở đây trong bị ăn mòn
khuyên bất ngờ cả nhà cái khác sầu thôi
tôi mua xem à Thôi ngồi Cố viết cái kia
cũng nghĩ về tưởng tượng cảnh mình mất
thôi rồi cậu vì giờ người thân mình có
thể buồn vì mình như nào vớ vẩn rồi kết
hợp với bản nhạc vậy chuyện nó cả khán
trường đấy ảnh khóc cười vì thế khi mà
mạng bọn Bằng cấp thì làm xong việc ở
ông ngồi khóc Hai ông ngồi cười vì nó là
nó điểm rồi Nó kêu là nó lừa được bởi vì
bản chất là lúc đấy thì ông sẽ
áo kiểu gỡ bỏ cái Hạnh bức tườngbức
tường ông đã giao ra đời mà
cậu Chạm vào nó thì giờ bọn nó thể len
lỏi vào trong tình cảm uống Nhưng suy
nghĩ là em cũng sẽ hiểu chị nay chuyện
bởi lời nói nó giờ thấy thấy thấy thấy
nói chung là cái buổi khóa lần đấy tôi
đi Ừ thôi bảo tôi tham đa cấp là đẹp hả
đi đèo gái
thì cái buổi lần đấy Thôi đi
hội Hảo lên đấy thấy thành công phết Cái
kiểu đó
họ còn họ còn là lừa được theo vụ là cả
các bạn phải có nhìn à Các bạn ơi nghe
cái vụ mà đi qua than hồng nữa chỉ có
than hồng ngược trở lại không phải có
lửa đâu mà đi qua than hồng Nếu bận than
hồng ở nhiệt độ
tháng nồng nhiệt độ nóng bao nhiêu tiền
rồi đấy ở người ta bảo nói chung là
2.000 độ hay cái gì đó nghe mày nói ghê
rồi bảo là nếu mà chân của mình bình
thường chạm vào đấy lâu sẽ bị bỏng đúng
không Nhưng mình phải có niềm tin là
mình thấy bước quá nhanh được đấy vân
vân đấy Hay sao ngồi cậu mọi người có
tin tôi không là họ làm
lòng khoan khoan qua hiểu cái kiểu nói
trước nó có rất nhiều cái trò hỗ trợ
mạng khơi gợi lòng tin lòng trắc ẩn đủ
cơ thể loại trong cái cái buổi hội thảo
đấy còn thêm cái vụ là
à à vụ là kêu bây giờ từng thành viên
trong nhóm Các bạn sẽ
chị sẽ ngã với người về phía sau và
những người có lại sẽ đỡ bạn mà không
chỉ đỡ là bình thường mà nhạc người ngã
ở trên cao xuống cơ của sợ vãi vừa đầy
tôi không dám làm vì tôi chẳng tưởng đứa
nào
và tôi bé nhất ở đây nữa mình kia mình
người kia Toàn anh chị và các bác ạ
à à
a nhớ đại khái là cái cái đấy đã khiển
nó tôi quay quay lại vấn đề một tí Ở đây
ít khi nó tôi nghĩ về cái kính nghĩa
cuộc sống của tôi khi mà tôi ra xử là
trong Nệm có cái câu đó là
Nếu giả sử của bạn được
bạn là một thiên thần được Phải đến cậu
Trái Đất những kiểu gì tôi không ngờ cái
cô ấy câu hỏi hay phết văn vở sẽ đấy thì
bạn
sứ mệnh của bạn là gì được cái thế chắc
chắn không phải đã cho rồi Chạy ghi vậy
ông đấy
nhưng mà lúc đấy Tôi nghĩ là kìa Nếu
thật sự là kiểu mình có một cái gì đó
Còn mục đích to lớn trong cuộc sống của
mình thì mình muốn là mình muốn chia sẻ
mình muộn người Kiểu
kiểu lại là chưa sẻ toàn bộ những cái mà
mình có thể kích thước có những ngày thứ
mình cảm thấy hay ho hay là cái tốt đẹp
này mình muốn lan tỏa được đấy
mà Đúng đấy Bây giờ tôi vẫn đang
phấn đấu làm điều đấy Kể tạo việc là
chia sẻ kiến thức cũng như là
chia sẻ mấy cái gái xinh hả những bức
ảnh đẹp Đối với tôi thì nhãn Vân Vân à
Ừ thôi tôi nhổ đi Cái bộ phải ý nghĩa
cuộc sống này bởi vì hôm trước cũng có
một bạn bình luận ở trên cái bài tâm sự
của tôi hỏi là ông đầy đang bị mất mục
đích sống
Ừ thì tôi có khuyên ông đấy là kiểu
Ê bà
Ừ cái mục cái mục đích sống ra nó vẫn
giống như vừa rồi nói về giống như cái
câu tôi là ai Nó mông lông là nó kiểu
nó bao la lắm nhiều thế không thấy ai
cũng trở thành một người ở vĩ nhân được
có người này người kia đúng không ạ
Nếu mà chắc chắn ở mình khó chịu với có
nhiều bạn bảo là mục đích sống của tôi
là tiền bụng vết xấu cho là ăn
cái mục đích bạn ấy nói có lấy không
biết đùa hay thật nhưng mà tầm nhìn thấy
nó bị hại quá đúng không ạ
du lịch sử và mình có một cái mục tiêu
gì đó to lớn cao lớn tí
mẹ con mình cố phấn đấu vì nó thì hơn
thay vì nó những cái hạn hẹp vừa rồi bởi
vì nghèo thì ông vẫn có tiền 12 nghìn
tiền
Ê mèo nằm thấy ăn được loại vân vân Nếu
mà ông có mục đích to lớn thì ông sẽ làm
được những người to lớn là thôi
à à
a
good fella server với tên miền nhưng nó
không tự chọn vào file Index II Ừ
chắc là bạn cứ hỏi thế chắc lại Xem lại
phải cốt các bạn xem lại file cốt của
bạn đấy thường là mặc định là file tên
là Yoona sấm p thì nó sẽ cho vào luôn
à à
Ừ
Ok
hôm nay không biết tâm sự thêm cái gì hả
mọi mình lâu mình còn chưa Chấm bài
không không bị lừa à
em tranh thủ chấm chấm luôn
ý nghĩa có bạn trả lời mấy câu xin đây
vậy ạ
Em gọi đi hát
a a
đấy còn chưa chữa về khâu SQL là đấy
chưa chữabài skul
thủ tục à
ở
với bạn này về cơ bản thử nó 7 cũng làm
tương đối ổn rồi
Ừ thế này là ổn rồi à
A2 ở Thôi bây giờ nghỉ tranh thủ đi trả
lời trước mấy câu này xong rồi hôm buổi
hôm nay cũng thể sẽ dài nữa nên là mình
sẽ
thì mình dậy nhé
đầu tiên thì hôm trước có bạn hỏi câu
này cái câu trong cốt của mình tự nhiên
có thêm cái đoạn cao sao các bạn biết
các bạn nhớ cái dòng này nó nằm ở chỗ
đoạn nào thấy tính năng nào thì có sinh
ra cái đoạn này không ạ
ừ ừ
thời trang mẹ ông không ngờ đó nghỉ
đi tí mình sẽ nhắc lại nếu mà có đề cập
đến nó là này nhá
tiếp theo là về mô hình thác nước ở
ông
bố ngồi cái Đoạn này đoạn phân tranh này
đoạn này là cậu để mà đến trên tổng số
tổng số sản phẩm này tổng số gì đó để
phân tranh dọn
những lúc lười thì thầy làm gì à
Dạo này tôi đang bị lừa đấy tôi bị lừa
cốt thấy cô ngồi chơi game thôi à
ừ ừ
Cô lười các bạn sẽ chơi game nghe nhạc
Nói chung là giải trí mà đúng ạ
Cũng Hôm trước có bạn hỏi về cái vụ là
thế thì mình đang làm đó theo mô hình
thác nước À thì mình xin phép chia sẻ
cái vụ đấy cho nhiều bạn chưa biết
các bạn các bạn sẽ hiểu xanh nước đấy Nó
là kiểu nó bản chất là nó chạy nó chảy
từ trên xuống dưới nó không có kiểu nó
không có kiểu là chửi ngược lại đúng ạ
thì thì gần như là cái mô hình thác nước
nó sẽ như này hình này cũng phải tương
có vẻ tương đối đúng thì mình sẽ nói Tại
sao từng nói đúng
Ô kìa Ở đây các bạn sẽ thấy là được đầu
tiên là sẽ có các yêu cầu này sau đó
thiết kế này thì thì mình kể về vụ đồ ăn
các bạn cũng thế
mình sẽ có những người yêu cầu phải phải
ghi đặc tả cho các thứ là kiểu
bên admin thì sẽ cần những tính năng gì
bên khách hàng cần những tính năng gì
Chuẩn bị buổi tối tôi sẽ bắt máy Ông
phải ghi tất cả những cái điều đấy tiếp
theo là cho từ đó chúng ta sẽ thiết kế
cứ kêu cái gì thiết kế và giao diện
thiết kế với cơ sở dữ liệu thiết kế về
sơ đồ thực thể này đấy
khi cây và ở đây thiết kế này nó sẽ bầu
có phân tích nhá đó là phân tích xem là
tính năng tính năng này phải cần làm như
nào vân vân vân đấy
Ồ không tôi không chuyên về anh đi mê
xuân của cs đâu Tao không thấy đâu
Tôi không dậy chưa người xét mà tắm rồi
có một cái trang chuyên dậy CS rất là
hay Tôi định chia sẻ trong mấy ông nhưng
mà tôi nghĩ là
mấy đó không cần nên chuyên CS tôi không
dậy ông kia đã hỏi đây cái cây này
online Totoro này cái nhà chuyên dạy CS
và kiểu cốt từ đầu đến cô ấy
bạn ấy không nói gì cả đâu với ông ạ Bạn
ấy có đến đâu ơi cho xem đến đấy hay
phết gửi trong đấy ông ạ
đi
đò tiếp theo
a tiếp theo là làm thì mình sẽ lập trình
nó giống họ mình dựa theo những cái
thiết kế mình lập trình Natri xong rồi
mình sẽ test để mà kiểm tra kiểm tra lại
hết một lượt xem nó ổn hay không Nhưng
mà thực ra trong ở đây Thế Thực ra nó
hơi bị như mình vẫn nói thời gian nó vẫn
còn hơi bị sai một tí bởi vì té xong mà
đương nhiên mà có lỗi thì anh em mình
cũng phải vòng lại đây là trình không ạ
nghĩa ghế đoạn này thì ra chuẩn đoạn này
nó sẽ phải hơi bị
cái đoạn này có thể nó là vòng lặp
ở đoạn này có thể ở phòng lập kiểu lập
trình sau đó thì test so Nếu có test mà
vẫn còn lỗi Huệ lập trình cái thứ Nói
chung riêng đoạn này lặp lại thôi Sau đó
thì tết xong rồi thì sẽ nhận sản vip loi
tất cả kiểu đầy nó lên trang web các thứ
thứ triển khai nó đúng không ạ sau đó
thì cái vụ bên tên là để bảo trì bảo trì
bản chất là nó cũng sẽ đến nó có thể
quay lại cái con này
phần kiểu lập trình sau lại test nó cứ
thứ
nhưng mà về cơ bản thì nó vẫn là mô hình
theo nước tất cả vào water flow tự water
food tới ga ở chạy từ trên xuống dưới
tại tại tại sao lại có cái mô hình này Ừ
cái mô hình này nó dụng khi nào để và nó
sẽ phù Nói chung là nó phù hợp trong
trường hợp nào nó phù hợp trong trường
hợp mà các bạn muốn làm một cái dự án
trong một khoảng thời gian xác định Gia
Xử giống như là
đó là sự giống như là bên A
ở
bên làm đồ án của mình chỉ trong vòng
hai ba tháng nữa là sẽ phải sóng Grow
bán thì nó khá phù hợp trong ô tô Ford
theo kiểu là
mình mình phải chốt thời gian chứ nếu mà
làm theo kiểu mô hình khác theo tưởng mô
hình thật sự là không bị lỗi là
cơm đâu mà IP đồ
lên đầu nha à
Anh ở trung mô hình này thì nó sẽ thường
ngay quay vòng trở lại cứ xong tính năng
nào đó thì mình sẽ lại kiểu kiểm tra lại
xem nó phù hợp với không do người còn
phát triển thêm tính năng nữa nghĩa là
cái mô hình này phù hợp để phát triển
thêm nhiều tính năng nữa các thử hướng
để cho sản phẩm trở nên hoàn thiện nhưng
mà chính vì như thế thì các bạn sẽ gần
như không bao giờ có chuyện nhảy sang
phần được sang phần kiểu cái tinh xong
rồi diploid cả vừa việc các bạn tốt quá
như là gian ở dai Đúng rồi Tao gửi ở ra
à
thì
các bạn sẽ tốn quá nhiều thời gian cho
gái vụ phát triển cái cái đấy phù hợp để
làm về phố đắp và hợp cho việc là có một
bên nào đó bà lại em muốn làm bao nhiêu
bao nhiêu thời gian được miễn là ngon
lành cành đào cho anh chú ngọn gió rất
trong tâm
[âm nhạc]
thực là cái cái cái đấy nó còn phải phù
hợp với việc vào ngân sách thoải mái bởi
water Phone này thì nó hợp với cái kiểu
là ví dụ như lúc đầu ông cho tôi 200
triệu thì tôi sẽ chỉ làm đủ sản phẩm kẹo
nó ổn phù hợp với giá 25 triệu con dẻo
dai thì thì nó là nó sẽ còn quay lại hỏi
khách hàng xem là khách hàng ưng này
chưa Khách hàng đó điều chỉnh nữa vân
vân thì chả nó tiền nó sẽ bị đẩy lên
công chuyện ở khách hàng sửa miễn phí
không ạ trấn thành ra là nó vừa bị rồi
thời gian nó vừa kẹo
kẹo làm cho nó các bạn mệt hơn cá nha bộ
phim
Nghe bài hát thành ra là
mình mình thì chỉ dạy các bạn đồ án theo
mô hình có được vô thôi nhưng mà đi làm
nhưng các bạn sẽ thấy nó khác đi làm các
bạn sẽ thấy nó theo kiểu bây giờ chủ yếu
là slime
ở dai đầu nhọn photo foody hợp để làm
cho mấy kiểu water phone lại hợp cho
mình cái dự án rất là to Điền hiệu của
chính phủ của mình theo kiểu là một vì
Ngân sách nó sẽ chỉ có gần đấy tia không
bao giờ hơn và phải bắt buộc trong một
khoảng thời gian nhất định không phát
gạo là không không được phép kiểu thay
đổi thời gian lắm Hay ra là kiểu những
cái dự án đấy Xin chào bạn thấy là làm
xong rồi Gần như là người ta sẽ ít Ít
tính năng và ít bạn chì kẹp Thế thì tác
hại bảo trì
ở đây do có rất nhiều trang web
trang web
á của chính phủ hay phần mềm của chính
phủ mà Ông thấy là tiền có thể tìm tỷ
đấy nhưng mà thật là kiểu trong nó cứ bị
cũng cũ và nó ít thì năng tự thứ nó cửa
bị khô xơ ấy đúng không
nhà đất mới nhất ở
à à
Ừ nếu hiểu đi
khi tôi đề cập Thế thôi nha Tôi không có
nó
động chạm gì đâu tiếp theo
Thế à HTML và mà gần thì nên đi thực tập
Fan thấy bác em ạ Phan ông Quý sanh ra
được 3 cái đúng cái sai ra được ok Thì
bạn này biết chồng có về biết hiểu đã
cửa là cả bên file xử lý file và cả bác
em nữa thì thực ra là nếu không nên biết
về xử lý với bảo lương cũng sẽ giữ hậu
hĩnh không phải về mỗi giao diện nữa
bộ phim
ở những nhưng mà mình nghĩ là cái này
thì bạn đấy phải theo thêm hướng gì nữa
vì hát về giao diện thì về các bạn thì
các bạn kiểu gì sẽ khởi động một tí theo
diện theo kiểu là phải có mắt thẩm mỹ
với Lý Còn bác em thì đúng chuyên về xử
lý hơn không cần phải kiểu có mắt thẩm
mỹ lương bây giờ hai bên nó đều tương
đương nhau nếu mà các bạn làm đều liên
quan bên xử lý
ở trường hợp một bạn bỏ giữa chừng thì
nhóm đó dậy sao hả anh Ờ cái này thì ra
còn tùy Bởi vì trong tuần này của mình
Mình vẫn đang khá thoải mái em cả là
mình đang kêu gọi là vẫn còn nhiều nhóm
vẫn còn chưa có bạn nào cơ chưa Bạn nói
lại Mình ra thì mà có nhóm thì mới chỉ
có một bạn
thì nên là mình đang xem cuối tuần này
xem tình hình các nhóm như thế nào để có
thể có thể là trong tuần này vẫn còn thì
có thể điều chỉnh để sắp xếp loại 1 và
nhóm
Vì thế nên con con sau đó nữa thì thì
mình sẽ cân nhắc trong một vài tình
huống là chị ạ Có thể bạn ấy sẽ chuyển
sang làm một mình thật ra là cho dù kể
cả làm một mình hay làm hai mình vẫn sẽ
có nhóm mà bạn kia làm nhiều hơn bạn còn
lại vẫn chỉ là bạn còn lại vì vấn đề gì
đó bạn ấy kiểu không theo kịp với Vân
Vân không làm được như vòng bạn kia trở
lại thì thì mình mình không biết mình
nói các bạn chưa Rồi Long Bình chấm mình
chấm thì sẽ là Dựa theo
sự cố gắng của từng cá nhân chứ không
phải là mình chấm cả thời trang web
bạn nào Ví dụ như mình nói là bạn nào
làm bên khách Hạnh bạn bên admin đúng ạ
Bạn làm bên admin thì mình sẽ chấm phần
bên em nhìn bạn này đã làm không ạ thì
nó sẽ tách biệt với cái bạn là mấy khách
hàng Bạn làm cái cái hàng có thể rất là
đểu thậm chí là trang web bên cái hàng
chẳng có chỗ nào sẽ được rằng mình sẽ
không đánh giá cái bạn làm đến 5 inch bị
ảnh hưởng nó sẽ luôn là độc lập thế nên
là
A và đi làm các bạn sẽ thế thôi đi làm
thì các bạn sẽ cố gắng hết sức của mình
chẳng ai có quyền đánh giá mạnh Nếu mà
xử cái sản phẩm nó có vấn đề vì người
khác cả mọi người ta sẽ không đổi việc
bạn vì bạn đã cố gắng thử Thế à Thế là
nên là bây giờ mình cũng sẽ chấm theo
kiểu hình thức như thế nghe các bạn đừng
lo khi mà kiểu dạng là sự mình làm bao
nhiêu việc thằng kia chẳng làm gì cả Nếu
như các bạn vẫn phải phản ánh lại với
mình để mình xem mình mình nói bạn đấy
được không hay là vân vân và nếu mà nếu
mà Giả sử bạn
anh không làm được với người ta người ta
không hề làm gì nữa người ta bỏ chặn ạ
Bạn sẽ nó nằm một mình ạ
Ừ thì mình vẫn sẽ giảm việc cho bạn mà
không cần yêu cầu cái trang web của bạn
khắc hay lắm đấy trong trường hợp mà giờ
xử không ghép được bạn với nhóm khác là
sự đang làm đến 60 phần trăm tiền đâu ở
trẻ em ạ thì sẽ khó mà ghép nhóm bạn với
người khác đi
Ừ thì bạn làm một mình thì chắc chắn à
Thì vẫn làm được thôi Bởi vì chính mình
đã từng một mình gánh cả đòn 1 đoàn 2
đoàn 3 à
em đứng yên à mình không nói mình có nhà
người ta hay gì cả mà chẳng qua là trong
23 tháng thừa sức bất kì ai làm một mình
đến một thời trang web quá vẫn quán dư
thời gian
à mà trong đi đó mình đã nói đó là mình
sẽ dạy các bạn từ đầu đến cuối cùng một
trang web cả tin tức cả bán hàng rồi các
bạn còn nhiều Xem toàn bộ như thế nào
mình gõ Cốt lại thì cũng cũng tương đối
tương đối với da đồng 10 sản phẩm rồi
i7 thế nên là các bạn không phải lo họp
với đi đấy Không phần loi thời gian này
không cần lo vị thành viên mình này mà
chị lo chính bản thân mình xem mình có
theo được hay không thôi Thế thôi Bọn
tiếp theo cái này tổ chức một lần hả
Thầy cái ý bạn này hỏi về cái việc à
bảo vệ quán này thì thực ra mình đang
định là cũng chưa Mình có đăng này mà sẽ
là tâm mà mua tháng một mình sẽ mở thêm
cho vay nhóm nữa có thể
anh cũng bắt tay vào làm nhưng mà sẽ bảo
vệ sau vậy Sao bọn mình
Ừ nếu giờ 23 tháng nữa thì chắc là mình
sẽ bảo vệ phải chắc là 6 tết nhà như sau
Tết âm hi vọng sau Tết âm Mấy ông không
có bị ăn bánh chưng xong quên hết ông ạ
ạ
các bạn có vừa nãy mình mới xem là có
bạn hỏi là nếu làm vài vết và một cái
cha mà chứa các mã không tồn tại thì trả
về nun hay là báo lỗi thời gian thì cả
hai nó vẫn đều là người dùng không được
phép đi
Ừ thứ nhất là người giàu không được phép
nhìn thấy cốt mình lỗi anh đúng không ạ
người dùng sẽ cần nhìn thấy cái gì người
dùng cần biết phải quay trở lại trang
khác hòa vào với đường lên khác đúng ạ
thì các bạn thì chả biết trang trắng
tinh Nếu mà hiểu về cơ bản thì chả thấy
cha trắng tinh thôi cũng được rồi Nếu mà
bạn hiển thị thêm mấy cái thông báo lỗi
thì dùng biết thì quay trở lại nữa thì
càng tốt không ạ không hiển thị lỗi đâu
nhé Nói chung là là khi mà bảo vệ đồ án
tới khuya là mấy ông sẽ phải không có
cái trường hợp nào khi bấm vào một cái
gì đó nói hiển thị Cái lỗi cốt của mấy
ông thế là 100 những cái điều tối kỵ khi
mà cậu Tuyết Trinh đúng hoặc tự nhiên
hiển thị ra dòng lỗi này lỗi tại dòng
bao nhiêu Vân chết đúng không ạ
a tiếp theo nào mình xin phép trả lời
cái câu mà hôm trước mình đã hỏi đó là
Đã có lúc ngồi trước thì có lúc mình đã
từng dùng cái này
I
wait you like Các bạn thấy vẫn chạy được
là xử với mình thử đi mua luôn nóng ạ
local hót à
trả lời giao diện khách hàng
ừ ừ
sữa
giả sữa vào đây
ở quản lý sản xuất này
à à
Anh An ninh bấm sữa này các bạn thấy ai
đi vòng 1 đúng ạ vì chưa và code của
mình hôm đấy Mình nhớ không lầm là cốt
của mình hôm đấy đã có
chị đã có
Where mã ID ở trong nhà trong trong cái
giàu nhà như thế này bơ giờ xử mình xóa
video nháy đi Các bạn thấy thực các cụm
Cốt nó vẫn chạy như thế cũng chẳng thay
đổi gì cả đúng ạ Tại sao đầu tiên là tại
sao đã đó là khi mà quen như thế này thì
cái ID của mình ở đây nó nó là nó là số
hàng ra là nó hoàn toàn hợp lệ trong
trường hợp này theo kiểu là các bạn nhớ
với mặt với AOE thì số thì có bạn không
cần phải để trong chống ngáy không ạ
Ừ nếu mà cũng chính vì cái câu mình vừa
nói là số không cần để trong rừng ái Tại
sao mình để nháy làm gì đúng ạ mình xóa
đi yêu phải trong nó tiện hơn không Cái
này là liên quan đến để toán là lại liên
quan Mai toán là cái lập trình viên
nhiều năm kinh nghiệm người ta sẽ thường
hay để trong dấu nháy Tại sao ạ bởi vì à
Nếu vì sau là sử là có vấn đề gì đó kiểu
dạng ID của mình không phù hợp với làm
việc theo kiểu là số ngày nữa mà đổi
sang Dạ chữ được cha và cha gì đó
Đó là kiểu chữ đó ngoại thì các bạn phải
sửa lại toàn bộ chỗ cốt mà thiếu dấu
nháy đấy
anh bởi vì ở toàn bộ Nếu nó là chữ chắc
chắn là đây là sự để chữ thản thì đây
Xóa đoạn này đi các bạn sẽ thấy nó lỗi
không ạ
xin lỗi như thế này bởi vì đây bây giờ
chữ chữa không thỏa mãn nữa rồi Còn nếu
để trong dấu nháy nó không sao cả
em đứng yên ở đây vẫn sẽ lỗi nhưng mà
không phải lỗi con chỉ cần nữa mà lỗi ở
đây là lỗi là không tìm thấy Không tìm
thấy cái thằng nào có mã bằng A trong
trường hợp mà nếu không tìm thấy thì như
vừa nãy mình vừa nói không tìm thấy thì
phải phải trả vậy Trang chống mày vừa
lội hay vì để nó chạy xuống cuối này lỗi
không ạ thì các bạn Thể chạy đoạn ở đây
đó là các bạn kiểm tra xem là
cho mình mình sẽ kiểm tra xem là cậu nó
có tồn tại tồn tại có bao nhiêu bạn ghi
không ạ sẽ là kiểu mình sẽ là số bạn đi
dâu chẳng number lô này
bằng mai que 5 pro II
em
bị sốt như lai
tra lại
ở đây trong trường hợp nhiễm mại ít
nằm 5 pro bằng bằng một rất là có một
bản ghi thì các bạn sẽ in ra
Ở Lại Nơi Này
bộ
dao này khi các bạn sẽ in ra là một cái
thẻ hát một chỗ to đây à
Không tìm thấy
à à
anh Treo mày chẳng lại
khá như này à
ở đó nhớ trong trường hợp mà Các bạn
truyền mãi mà không hợp lệ làm thì nó sẽ
như thế này còn nếu mà mã hợp lệ cử như
thế này
ở lại mà không hợp lệ lại
các loại hiệu trưởng
trở lo lắng chỉ là mình sẽ dùng cái Hàn
mowry năm dâu đếm xem là là cái kết quả
trả về nó là bao nhiêu bạn ghi Ừ nếu nó
là một ẩn gì rất là nó đúng rồi thì mình
sẽ chạy như bình thường Còn nếu mà em là
ngược lại đúng không ạ thì mình sẽ in
thẻ h1o là không tìm thấy Ông Ngoại thế
được
à à
Ừ Ok thì bây giờ mình sẽ
và buổi hôm nay nhá và Bồ Hôm nay thật
rất là dài đấy
bắt đầu từ bây giờ là buổi nào Hùng Tiến
đấy Chẳng biết là có khó đủ thời gian để
chia sẻ những bạn thứ hay ho khác không
hiện đại khái nó sẽ dài đây bây giờ đầu
tiên thì mình sẽ cầm là lên
sân bay Đông ạ
Đúng rồi nhìn cái thẻ đóng hay mở của TP
như này trong một khá xấu Vì công nhận
cho khá xấu như này và nhiều lúc của bạn
mình mình mình là mình thêm cái tiện ích
Nếu các bạn để ý kĩ là mình thêm với chị
ích ở đây thông báo là nó có mở mở còn
đây và đóng ở đây này còn các bạn mà
quên không thêm cái tiện ích đấy các bạn
không nhớ được là đã mở Em mở cái ngoặc
nhọn ở đâu để đóng được đâu các thương
Nếu mà quên đóng thì các bạn chắc chắn
nó sẽ bị lỗi như này thôi tôi sẽ bị lỗi
anh như thế này Cái lỗi này lỗi xin xin
Alo lỗi của Pháp Nói chung mà các bạn
làm việc với TP nhiều ấy thì chất rắn à
các bạn sẽ quen việc nó thông báo rất
nhiều cái lỗi và các bạn sẽ phải quen
đọc lỗi gì nó
thì các bạn không quen lập lỗi nói gì
đấy thì các bạn sẽ không biết cách dbox
không ạ
à Hôm nay mình sẽ làm thêm về foods ở
phố đắt thì bản chất
khi
nó là sản phẩm thì tức à
đây tay để mình Nó qua một tí cũng trước
là về nhà sản xuất đúng ạ
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ có đề minh họa nhé à
là
một nhà sản xuất
thì tạo được
có bao nhiêu sản phẩ à à
à à
là một nhà sản xuất thì tạo được bao
nhiêu sản phẩm I
em có nhiều sản phẩm hãy trả lời rồi
Nhiều lúc ạ ok
Ừ
thì mình sẽ để nó lo mặc các bạn kia trả
lời nghe lời cho bạn biết rồi Tiếp theo
một sản phẩm
được tạo bởi bao nhiêu nhà sản xuất à
anh không nợ
ở ngoài chuẩn trong trường hợp này là 1n
và không n vẫn cũng đúng
Ai bảo Arsenal không cần bắt buộc
em nấu ăn thường là một sản phẩm thì có
thể tạo bởi một nhà sản xuất thực ra thì
topic thực tế thì có thể làm nhiều nhưng
mà mình làm đơn giản thì nó làm theo
kiểu mô hình đơn giản đấy thì nó sẽ là
một thì nó sẽ đơn giản Còn nếu mà theo
nhiều thì nó bày trò nó phức tạp của nó
phức tạp hơn
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là mối quan hệ giữa
nhà sản xuất với với sản phẩm nó sẽ là
mối quan hệ một lọ hoa giống như bạn kia
vừa nãy nói thì có thể không ngờ Tức là
tất cả ám chỉ là là không chính xác là
không phải không nở đâu mà nói là
thì nó vẫn là một lời thôi để làm chị ạ
một hàng có thể tạo được và không tạo
được sản phẩm nào
đề
thi cái cái vừa rồi mình nói về cái vụ
một lời ấy tất cả sao Tức là sản phẩm sẽ
luôn phải lưu lại mã nhà sản xuất phải
luôn có mãi nhà sản xuất ở trong bảng
sản phẩm
đề mà hiểu được là thằng nào thằng tạo
ra nó
không phải là nhà sản xuất có mã sản
phẩm vào nhé bởi vì nhà sản xuất mà lưu
lại mã sản phẩm thì thành nhà suốt đấy
lại lưu lại quá nhiều quá nhiều cái sản
phẩm
anh theo kiểu là cột đấy nó sẽ thấy cột
3 chị thì không tốt mà phải là sản phẩm
lưu lại mã ngành sản xuất đúng ạ
Cái này hồi mình dạy về ashwell về lớp
với sinh viên để cho bị nói qua các bạn
rồi
bây giờ thì sản phẩm thường hay mình sẽ
lưu lại thêm mã này tên này ảnh này
Ý giá này
thì các bạn là như thế có thể thêm số
lượng cũng được nhưng mình khuyên là các
bạn làm đơn giản thì các bạn không nên
thêm số lượng Tại sao vì
vì số lượng nào số lượng các bạn Nhập về
hay số lượng ba còn trong kho ừ ừ
ạ Và nếu mà các bạn thêm số lượng là các
bạn sẽ phải làm là khi mà giả sử mình
làm trang web bán hàng không ạ táo khi
mà khách hàng đặt hàng các bạn phải thêm
một cái đoạn thì kiểm tra xem số lượng
nó có
vì nó có đủ thỏa mãn để mà các bạn bán
sản phẩm đấy không Thế nên mình tạm bỏ
qua số lượng cứ coi như là số lượng của
sản phẩm này Thoải mái đi mình đặt bao
nhiêu thì mình đều có thể mình đều có
thể sản xuất được đều có thể bán được
còn nếu mà các bạn lưu lại số lượng thì
các bạn sẽ phải thêm cái đoạn cốt để
kiểm tra xem là có đủ số lượng để bán 20
số lượng còn trống kho này Vân Vân Vân
thì bài toán ơi nó sẽ phức tạp hơn rất
nhiều
anh hạnh phúc nào hơn đấy bởi vì không
phải mỗi kiểm tra như thế đâu nhá Giả sử
là các bạn bán đất được một sản phẩm Ví
dụ ở sử lớp đầu số lượng trong kho của
các bạn là mười không ạ xong rồi có một
bạn đặt đơn là bạn 5 cái nó ạ Thì rõ là
các bạn sẽ phải cập nhật số lượng lại
chậm kho lại hàng còn 5 chẳnghạn đúng
không Nhưng mà giả sử là cái khách hàng
kia lại hủy hóa đơn này đi thì các bạn
lại phải mất thêm một đoạn cốt nữa thì
cập nhật lại số lượng đông ạ Các bạn
hiểu ý mình không ạ thì các bạn sẽ thấy
đó à sẽ phải làm làm thêm đoạn Cốt và
kiểm tra khá nhiều với đoạn số lượng là
Cập nhật lại số lượng nữa
cho nên à cái bài toàn đấy nó hơi bị
nghiệp vụ một tí và sáng tạo hơn một tí
thì mình nghĩ bậy xanh đồ bàn hay nó sẽ
phù hợp hơn
chị còn đoán bộ thì mình cứ làm đơn giản
thì cậu là
à à hiển thị l sản phẩm cho khách hàng
đặt đặt được nhiều sản phẩm các thư vân
vân là được rồi lại thành công luôn đi
vụ tai nạn tương đối này 55 cụt Đúng rồi
còn mô tả đúng ạ sản phẩm cái mô tả chứ
ông không phải nhìn mỗi cái ảnh cho anh
xem giá phục hồi ông đạt được đúng không
ạ sửa 6 đi 300 cái chip câu nó là cái
bên nâng cao ý thì mình sẽ không dậy
mình không dạy các bạn sử dụng à
Ê mày cài Apple nâng cao chuyên sâu mà
mình đã từng dạy các bạn
ở trong cái
về thực tế thì mình đã từng nói thực tế
được là Ý công ty áp dụng mày cả đấy chỉ
có dụng mỗi view rõ ra
Index trong dự án thực tế thôi còn chị
girl này hay là của Cydia thì ít Công ty
áp dụng mà người ta sẽ ghi thẳng vào
trong cốc thì xử lý chứ không xử lý em
sẽ dp như thế mình dậy do các bạn thì
các bạn biết thôi I
à à a name nên cứ để 50 thoải mái rồi
ở đó thì ở đây là ảnh
ảnh này thì có bạn bảo muốn lưu lại như
vậy nhưng mà lưu lại nhiều ảnh thì nó sẽ
phải ba chị đúng không ạ Mình đang lưu
lại theo kiểu đơn chị là chỉ có một ảnh
thôi tạm chấp nhận như thế
về giá trial
có đèn flash cũng được à à
à à
ở
mô tả
description hội chả nhớ viết viết cái
này nữa cơ đấy Này làm tách này và ờ
e-manifest ID này kiểu in Ok trong bể
đúng đấy
ảnh 3D để như vừa nãy bạn kia nói về
khóa khoa ngoại
ở khoa ngoại khóa ngoài có ngoại thì các
bạn sẽ Nhấn vsphere ở đây này rồi các
bạn sẽ tạo khoa ngoại cho nó sẽ là kiểu
nối cột manifesta này vỡ bạn marphasol
Tại nó sẽ gợi ý đây cột ID học ở đây còn
hai cục lên của việc một nếp là unique
thì các bạn vẫn hình nối được nhưng
không anh nối yêu đấy cả
ở đó thì bây giờ nó sẽ có ràng buộc
khoáng ngoại để ông ạ nghĩa là khi mà
nhà sản xuất nào mà có sản phẩm rồi thì
khi mà xóa nhà suốt đây đi sẽ bị cảnh
báo tám triệu không được phép xóa tại
Khánh Như thế
Ok Bây giờ thì
thì mình sẽ thứ nhất là mình sẽ thêm vào
trong máy new thế mà trong menu các bạn
nhờ menu ạ Mình sẽ có ghé Hôm trước mình
có cái vụ mẹ ngủ đây
là quản lý nhà xuất giờ mình sẽ thêm
quản lý sản phẩm không ạ
mà đổi đây sẽ bù đắp ạ
anh như này
khi mình bấm lại
Em không tìm thấy vì chưa có tạo nóng ạ
tạo phụ đề là phố đắc ý
À hôm nay mình mình sẽ chốt nhanh hơn
rất nhiều Sau hôm trước nhé bởi vì mình
hai hôm mà ông ạ tính cách chấm Pain
sẽ là một là quản lý sản phẩm
sẽ for PC trên
Hari White
menu
bị fan nằm ngoài
này
có thấy bồ này à
nhà mình cần kết nối cơ sở liệu đã nóng
cái nồi cơ sở liệu để mà
chị địa địa toàn bộ các sản phẩm thì sẽ
là
lại thêm liky
con ếch chấm thấy phê này
mà cô ấy quelle sẽ là select sao Ford
Ford
kết quả trả về này
ai đi
nhập mã luôn mã
trên ảnh giá
ở mô tả thì có bạn không cần hiển thị vì
mô tả mà rất là dài các bạn nhưng bấm nó
xem chi tiết thì hơn
lại khá như thế ư
có ai mình sẽ là phối cái đây này
từng kết quả này
Đây là ai đi này nên ô tô này
và y là giá cho này
cho
biết các bạn nhìn cốt có nhìn rõ nhỉ à
vì
vậy Nhìn nó rõ nhé
ừ ừ
anh
chàng này không có gì mới chưa có sản
phẩm gì cả à
Ừ mạng mình sẽ có thể à
Thêm à
A
One Piece a.ve
anh
em Alo ạ Ừ cái mình sẽ copy rồi đoạn này
đi
à à
ừ ừ
ở đây sẽ có tên YouTube
sex
anh
lần này mình sẽ dạy cho các bạn luôn cả
à Hấp load được file này lên luôn không
ạ
Giá này
anh giá mô tả ừ
khi con gì nữ Hà Nội nhà xuất Ngoại Ô
à à
ở
mô tả thì nó sẽ đưa kết chân tôi quên
cách viết của - Quyết chiến đấu
thế
expression
có toàn không ngờ cách viết từ đấy trong
dài vãi
a
new for a
à à
Bạn đoạn này các bạn sẽ thấy là trước
trước trước nghe thấy thì các bạn sẽ
thấy khó chịu ở cái đoạn này đó là phần
Nhàn Suốt này các bạn sẽ thành nhập lại
cái đúng ngay đi của cái nhà sản xuất
thực ra là người dùng không nhớ được cái
đi của nhà suốt nó là gì đâu không ạ Nên
có đoạn này không nên để cho khỏe Ôi
phút nhập như này Đấy do mình có cái
loại snack ở trên này mình sẽ là select
thường người ta sử select toàn bộ
ừ ừ
an toàn bộ nhà hàng xuất ở đây sau đó
thì mình sẽ làm gì mình sẽ có cái ô xà
lách áp trưng ở đây nào
mà mình sẽ còn lên mà nó là mono fossil
luôn
ai đi và mình sẽ vòng lặp for us như thế
này
và mình sẽ và có bao nhiêu thằng có bao
nhiêu thẳng nhà sản xuất thì mình sẽ là
bình ôsin ở đây như thế này
mà valeu của cái thương gót chân đấy bản
chất nó lại là từ ngay đi của cả nhà sản
xuất chứ không phải từng nêm ở nhà xuất
tại nó sẽ kiểu như này
Ừ để khi mình bấm là mình chọn cái gì đó
như này trở lại thì nó vẫn thêm mày các
bạn sẽ thấy là nó sẽ chuyên nó thành địa
chỉ có là ai đi vòng sáu này hoặc có ai
đi bằng một loại khác như thế như thế
này đúng không ạ đó
a
tiếp theo là
Em nhớ là phải để mấy thớt của cái phòng
này sẽ làm biết hết là tốt không ạ
Và á chân thì sẽ nhảy đêm Cái pha là cô
set in search này
và còn thêm một cái nữa đó là nếu mà
file file ảnh như này đúng hạn thì các
bạn sẽ phải thêm một cái đoạn nữa là mã
hóa nó and Chris thôi không nhớ nó lắm
đâu các bạn thường anh cha em clip HTML
form như thế này
thì nó sẽ ra
thì các bạn copy đoạn này là được đoạn
này nó là gì chị để cho phép các bạn
trong phone của hệ truyền đến được file
đấy
thứ Ba phải tải lại đúng không ạ
Ừ để tải được trên Face rồi Cá thứ rồi
chồng có vẻ Tôi muốn mình sẽ nhập nha
iPhone không ạ
em giá 10k
hình ảnh
xu hướng dẫn nhiều Anh
Anh hãy kiểm tra trở lại ạ
Ừ đúng rồi dùng mấy cái kia thì tốc độ
truy vấn hay các thứ mọi thứ sẽ nhanh
không ạ Nhắn chậm là
ý là bây giờ khi mà lưu lại cái đấy
trong ta bay thì người đi người sau khi
người sẽ không biết được
anh đột nhiên ở tự nhiên ông chạy một
cái gì đó tự nhiên ngày kia đó lập tức
được chặn mà trong khi đó mò cốt mãi
không thấy thì ông sẽ thắc mắc mà giờ họ
rất khó để sửa không không biết gì không
sửa được cái ra à bây giờ ít công ty áp
dụng rồi đấy
ở đây sẽ là
từ táo cắn dở này
sẽ nặn em buồn thêm
ý dĩ nhân bây giờ chưa thêm được không ạ
Mình sẽ là tạo file mới
mình bỏ qua bộ váy đẹp có thừa thôi nha
các bạn sẽ phải tự làm virus các thử nha
mình sẽ nêm này bằng đô la poste nêm ạ
hình ảnh này
chợ hoa ảnh giá Mô tả sản xuất còn thiếu
niên 12345
Ừ ừ như vậy lại năm cũ thì phải
à à
xe ô tô đậu hũ
a
Price IS ờ ờ
t-express kinh
Hình như đúng
a
Mano ê
Ừ nhưng mà cái đoạn này các bạn thấy là
riêng cái file này hiểu chưa Lên các bạn
sẽ không dùng được cái đô la poste kiện
này đâu các bạn sẽ phải dùng cho pha như
thế này tự nhiên phải thêm chữ s nữa cơ
thì lòng ra đúng được đâu ạ và đấy Cái
thứ nhất thứ hai là khi chuyển pha lên
thế này như mình đã từng nói các bạn Nếu
mà chưa Nhớ thì các bạn
bây giờ mình nhắc lại cái local host này
chính là con máy ảo
Ừ đúng ạ cái file mình vừa chọn lại từ
trên cái con mày thật của mình Thức ạ Cứ
cả máy ví dụ mày chết hàng không ạ máy
khách hàng 7 cái file ảnh đầy lên con
máy ảo như này
có phải đẩy file lên và mình lưu lại cái
pha đấy ở trên trên con máy ảo của mình
Tại sao lại phải làm thế ạ Mình cần lưu
lại và cái ảnh đấy vào trong thư mục gốc
của mình này lưu lại ở trong cái con máy
ảo mình ra sự con mèo mình bây giờ trong
trường học này nó có server tệ tên là j
high school Đúng không ạ bởi vì à
Ừ Nếu mình không lưu lại thì mình sẽ
không
không thể có thể lần sau giày truy cập
được cái file ảnh từ trên máy khách hàng
nữa Đúng là đơn giản thế thôi nghĩa là
khách hàng ban ảnh lên thì mình phải lưu
lại để mà Lần sau mình hiển thị lại ra
gái không ạ Mình mình không thể cái nồi
để cái ảnh đấy Lần Nữa ở trên máy khách
hàng được không ạ Mình chưa có thể lưu
lại trên trên trên chính máy trên gọi là
chuyến server mình để mình hiển thị ra
Ừ nó nó giống như kiểu bây giờ mấy ông
ta lại lên Facebook đấy bản chất là
Facebook mà sẽ lưu lại ảnh của ông ở
trên máy chủ của nó để bề mà khi mở Ông
đăng nhập bằng máy khác thì ông có xem
được ảnh của ông đối ngoại người khác
cũng thể xem được ảnh của ông bởi dao
ảnh đấy ra công khai ở trên máy chủ của
nó đơn giản thế thôi đúng ạ
thì cái việc lấy cái ảnh để lên thì rất
ra mình sẽ dùng cái hàm hàm khi mà cái
file này được tăng lên nó sẽ luôn nằm ở
trong thư mục quả là ten nó thư mục tem
tất cả thư mục tạm thời
Ừ nó chưa hề được lưu lại ở trong cái
server của mình các bạn thấy à đâu nằm
thì có cái ảnh nào đây đâu đúng ạ mình
Thứ nhất là mình nên tạo một cái thư mục
để mà chưa cái ảnh đấy thay vì kiểu lưu
bừa ở bất kỳ đâu thì nó sẽ bị về sau mới
nhiều ảnh của anh sự giác như các bạn
nên lưu lại ở trong một thư mục thường
là mình sẽ lưu lại ở thư mục và đây Giả
sử Trong trường hợp này mình tại một thư
mục nữa Đây là thư mục Phố Đôi này ạ à
Photo để ạ
Vì mình nghĩ mình nên tắm vào đâu nhỉ
anh Bởi vì bản chất là
bên này bên admin à
bên này bên emminh Bình Tổng thư mục ảnh
ở cái chỗ ở đây đi là sự tạm đấy nhé ô
tô ngay đúng không ạ Đấy mình sẽ về sau
sẽ tống hết ảnh vào trong mục photo này
vi phạm và cái như mình vừa nói là cái
thư mục là khi mà ảnh được đẩy lên nó
luôn lưu hội và trong thư mục tạm thời
này mình phải chuyển cái ảnh ở thư mục
tạm thời là như copy nó là chuyển nó vào
cái thu mục photo này nên là sẽ sẽ có
khái niệm mà dùng cái hạ mu mu file ảnh
thử thế thực là mình đang nói về cái kéo
mặt nhiệm vụ rồi được bạn Tôi cũng không
nhớ Toàn bộ cốt để làm đâu nên tôi
thường này lên đây để cốt
amplified à
ở tp lapisschool mày ông sẽ lên đây Cốc
Cốc
ở đầu tiên ở trên này nó hướng dẫn đầy
đủ đầu tiên là các bạn phải chỉ là phải
cho A flash file này thường là server nó
đôi khi nếu các bạn thấy học sinh thường
là nó sẽ tắt cái đi chợ này nếu mà lag
ol2shop in các bạn cài ngay cả cái này
thường nay được mở rồi các bạn không cần
quan tâm nữa
tiếp theo là có cái phom để mà truyền
file lên này không ạ sau đó thì đây là
đoạn cốt Bạn cố này đoạn cốc giữ cơ bản
mà chỉ đơn giản đã có thư có thư mục này
sau đó đi lấy tên file này sau đó thì
cái đoạn này thì cốt là để mà cậu anh
nói chung là sửa lại tên file có thử thứ
sau đó đi Thanh Vân kiểm tra xem file có
đúng là file ảnh không file
ạ sau đó đi đây là
Ừ đúng rồi Có đúng là file ảnh hay không
à đấy có thư thực ra là
em kéo xuống dưới này thì các bạn sẽ
thấy là ở đây người ta đã vi Hàn đoạn
cốt rất là dài từ đầu đến cuối cốt là để
mà kiểm tra xem file phải phải ảnh 20
này phải đã tồn tại chưa Này độ dài của
a nội dung lượng của file còn lớn hay
không này Đấy xong rồi có đúng định dạng
ảnh ấy không này tại như này
Ẩm Thực ra là nếu mà các bạn không cần
phải va biết chị quá như thế này thì nó
rất là nắn sẽ có một đoạn ngắn hay Thôi
để tôi trông sẽ nó sẽ chỉ dùng hàng này
chuyển file chỗ này thế thôi
à à
ý
thì cái test file này chính là cái file
a file mình sẽ chậu lưu lại nó ở đâu vậy
Mình tỷ tỷ
Ừ mình kéo ok
thì nó sẽ lưu lại phải ở đâu cái file
này như mình vừa nói mình sẽ lại ở trong
thư mục photo không ạ
Giả sử mình sẽ có phô đô là
cô đơn vì cái đúng nhỉ Phủ được à
Ừ đúng rồi biết được
lâu không động và tiếng Anh nháo không ạ
mày cái chéo nhé bớt mùi thì phải trèo
nhé Đây là thư mục mà mình sẽ lưu vào
đúng ạ tiếp theo là tên của Wifi đấy bản
thân ghẻ phải đăng lên thì có bạn phải
lấy tên được cái file thì tên file đó sẽ
là gì Các bạn xem qua đây này
xe tải tên file nó sẽ là chế độ này ạ à
à
ở lại nó sẽ là
bí thư mục thư mục mạch kết hợp với cái
file truyền lên đây này Ở đây trong
trường hợp file mình chuyển lên nó sẽ là
cái đoạn này thôi
photo này mình sẽ lấy bay nên tức là lại
cái tên gốc của nó
Chờ Đợi mình tí nhá ở đây nó có kiểm tra
cả
ở đuôi định dạ
anh không không không cần không quan tâm
mình thử bay cái
tên của file cho bạn xem nhé
Sau đó các bạn sẽ thấy là file nó sẽ cho
nó sẽ lưu lại ở trong cái đường dẫn là
như thế này mình đang cần phải lấy cái
hướng dẫn mà Đây chính là đường dẫn của
file file nó sẽ có đơn giản là như thế
này là nằm trong thực sẽ nằm trong thư
mục photo này tên gốc của nó là như thế
nào đuôi file đó như thế nào như này Ok
thì ở đây mình nếu mà đặt tên chuẩn hơn
thì phải phát file tất cả động dẫn của
file nói chuyện hơn là như này
sự thay đổi photo lại thành đoạn này
được
đây file lúc đầu sẽ nằm ở trong thư mục
tạm thời nhá sau đó chuyển vào cái file
như kia là sao Hay tôi thử chạy thử mấy
ông xe này ạ
em có ảnh rồi
Ừ Ok chưa
thế nhưng đây sẽ có nhược điểm nó sẽ có
nhiều điểm bởi vì do cái ảnh vừa rồi của
mình nếu các bạn để ý cái ảnh của mình
vừa rồi của mình tên nó là như thế này
tên nó được cả làm con số ngẫu nhiên gì
đó rồi
những bài thơ cho ông xe máy anh
ạ Bây giờ tôi Giả sử tôi đổi về tên file
này tên là A chuẩn B ng chẳng hạn đúng
you are in png Nha
Ừ tôi chọn lại cái file.vn khuẩn
Ở đây có thêm à
Ừ nếu không sẽ xảy ra nó ra đời ảnh a.vn
đúng nghĩa lấy được đúng cái tên gốc của
cái file ảnh đó ông ạ ok
ạ Bây giờ tôi đổi cái file tên là bê tôi
đội ảnh khác tên là Nhạn bê rất là anh
khác không ạ
xe tải tôi lại chọn lại cái ảnh là a
chấm b ng này đây rất là làng khác Chẳng
qua trùng tên không ạ bấm và này
anh không thấy nó bị ghi đè lên bằng cái
ảnh khác bởi vì sao Bởi vì đơn giản thôi
bởi vì nói chung Tết đúng ạ thì cái cái
trường hợp này là cái trường hợp mà
không nên không nên đó làm chỉ các bạn
nếu mà vẫn giữ nguyên cái tên file ảnh
mà khách hàng đẩy lên đấy Chắc chắn là
ảnh để có thể bị trùng tên và nó sẽ ghi
đè lên như thế và ghi đè lên như thế là
hỏng rồi đúng ạ Vì người dùng đặt tên sẽ
làm linh tinh không ạ
Vì thế nên là mình cách làm của mình và
làm sao cho cái tên file của nó không bị
chung mà thường không bị trùng thì có
thể là chơi như cách mà lấy nhiều thời
gian hiện tại theo kiểu My nó sẽ không
bờ sẽ rất hiếm trường hợp trùng không
nói chuyện là hai ông ăn Min cũng đăng
và cùng cái đi đây cả Không ạ Cái cách
để lấy tro Ly mình mình sẽ đặt tên file
nó sẽ bây giờ mình sẽ đặt tên file là gì
thì mình sẽ đặt tên file là Minisa cái
thời gian hiện tại
cộng với đuôi của file
a
wifi
Nhưng mà nãy giờ các bạn thấy là để mình
thử dê dê cái
à à đẻ mình inna gái này Win
Photo để các bạn xem qua Cài file ảnh
của mình bạn chất lúc đầu nó sẽ có những
cái gì nhé á
ở đây nó sẽ có là gì
Anh tên file là gì này định dạng file là
gì này cái này dậy hơi khó lấy và tiếp
theo là file đang lưu tại thư mục đường
dẫn mặc định là gì đó thu mục tạm thời
nhờ ông ạ và size của pha là gì này à
Ừ Thì bây giờ mình lấy mình cần lấy cái
trắng bên là giờ này thì cách để lấy nó
là mình sẽ lấy á
và đương nhiên là thường mình thưởng ai
lấy Sẽ thưởng ai sau dấu chấm
mình sẽ thường lấy Sau đó chấm
Ừ mai mình sẽ có về à
à à
I
find extension đuôi định dạy một vài này
sẽ bằng photo tại nêm này
và sau dấu chấm thì sẽ có dùng hàm acro
được
ở
hà max pro này tức là sao nó sẽ cắt cái
chuối
một
chuỗi tên của ảnh cắt nhau bởi dấu chấm
và mình sẽ lấy hàng ở vị trí thứ 1 Đức à
sau khi ở cắt xong mà biến hình mạc
Thành A là nó sẽ là vị trí không thằng B
ng sẽ vị trí một mình sẽ lấy thằng vị
trí thứ 1 thì sẽ ra được đuôi pha
và bây giờ mình sẽ có
Anh tên Tiến ảnh sẽ giống như bạn Dũng
Bùi và nói dùng hạn tham cũng được cái
lấy thời gian hiện tại nó sẽ là sông Hàn
tham này sau đó thì nối nhau bởi Dấu
chấm này
và nối tiếp với đuôi của pha đây Bye à
Sau đó các bạn sẽ thấy nó bây giờ thì
thể file ảnh nó sẽ luôn nó sẽ là thời
gian và nó sẽ không có chuyện nói chung
cái tả lại các bạn thấy thay đổi số rồi
ông ạ Em ở mình như này đó sẽ ra đời một
cái ảnh như này Vợ mình tải lại nó lại
ra ảnh nữa Cái này có hơi bị nhược điểm
một tí của vì a Chính vì do là nó thời
gian nó không bao giờ kiểu trùng nên là
các bạn mà cơ vừa rồi mình Các bạn thấy
ra cứ mỗi lần mình tại lại trang thì nó
lại in sốt ra thêm một cái ảnh nữa đóng
ngoặc thì ra thế này hơi bị nhược điểm
nên là nhiều nôi thì nó lại làm theo cơ
chế nó sẽ lưu lại cái ảnh theo ID của
cái vô Đắc cũng được cũng được làm theo
kiểu lạ
Anh làm chỉ làm 11 Cô Đắc thì sẽ không
một ảnh là sự thế và khi mà
force xóa đi thì sẽ xóa cái theo cái ảnh
đấy cũng được không sao cả
à Còn bây giờ mình chị đã nói vụ là để
mà tránh chồng đi Đây là một cách không
ạ nhưng nó sẽ nhược điểm các bạn vừa
thấy nếu mà ảnh mà giống hệt nhau thì nó
vẫn sẽ là bị trùng vẫn bị lặp lại đúng
không ạ
vì
sao mình không lấy tên mà nhà sản xuất
đã không không Mình lưu lại là mình lưu
lại chóng mã mà mình không lưu lại thiệu
tên
vì mình lưu lại trong đêm Bên mình có
loại theo mã không ạ
tên có thể thay đổi khuẩn mã gì nó sẽ
không thay đổi Mình sẽ lưu lại theo cái
mã thôi
anh nói chung là nãy giờ này anh khai
các bạn thấy không bị mất công người
đoạn mỗi đoạn về ban file lên để bọn
mình sẽ làm ngay
a
knack này pin
lại tôi đang dậy rồi à từ từ có nhiều
bạn mà biết đoạn này rồi các bạn sẽ thấy
cát dài lắm
nhưng mà thế này nó mới kiểu tương đối
đầy đủ nó không ạ ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi lưu lại theo mã sản phẩm thì
nó ổn nhưng với các bạn như các bạn sẽ
phải đi sốt chưa Đã rồi các bạn xưa nek
lại thì các bạn bị lấy được cái cài
mã của sản phẩm nhưng mà cái bài toán
Lưu lại hai mã sản phẩm thì nó phù hợp
với việc là một sản phẩm một ảnh thôi
còn nếu mua sản phẩm nhiều ảnh thì cách
này nó phù hợp hơn lại đâu ạ tất cả các
bạn lại có thể chơi cái trò là tạo hẳn
thư mục theo mã sản phẩm sao lưu lại tất
cả ảnh trong cái Không mục đấy
tư nhân ảnh vẫn thể chung nhá Nhưng mà
về sau giải quyết bài toán đơn giản khi
mà mình xóa sản phẩm thì mình sẽ còn xóa
cái thư mục theo ID của phạm sản phẩm
cũng được
anh nói chung là mình đang dậy vẫn là
chỉ mức Cơ bản mình chưa nói bài toán
tối ưu Ở đây các bạn sẽ có thể sẽ thắc
mắc thì mình mới ra đã chứ bây giờ mình
mà cứ chuyên sâu về cái tối ưu quá cũng
như dạy các bạn chuyên sâu quá các bạn
sẽ thấy nó bị phức tạp lên và các bạn sẽ
bị đau đầu đúng không ạ Thế mình vẫn thì
đang dạy các bạn mức tương đối các bạn
thôi
nhưng mà các bạn mà hỏi thì mình sẽ trả
lời ok không ạ Chứ không phải là tôi
không biết mấy điều đấy đâu
a cho tôi dậy trong bé ông Toàn người
nâng cao rồi mấy ông sẽ thấy được quay
mang tiếng nhà
cơ bản mà Tôi thấy đau đầu quá thức rằng
những cái Nãy giờ đang nói nó cũng có tí
nâng cao tí rồi
tính đến nhiều trường hợp nó là nâng cao
đấy ạ
ở
chung Kitty linh tinh rồi không có Star
hiện
Tôi không cần mấy ông Ba để kiếm thương
khác nữa nhé
á đấy thỉnh thoảng quên không đóng phí
nỗi này thì chả thời đóng kết nối trong
ngày vui này
chạy chạy này tạm thời không xem lỗi gì
cả nhé
à à quên quên quên bây giờ không phải
photo là à Bây bị lỗi các bạn cũng thấy
này I'd like to drink nữa là Cái lỗi này
lỗi khi mà mạng nó đang bị biến thành
chuỗi
bạn trong trường hợp này photo đang làm
à nếu các bạn vừa nãy để ý không ạ Bây
giờ mình sẽ chỉ cần lưu lại tên của file
và đường dẫn mình cái ai đừng dẫn ở
trong trường hợp này nó sẽ ra phát file
này sẽ lưu lại cái này
Anh
tên file cũng được
Anh tên file ảnh thì nếu Thế bên phải
hạn thì xảy ra file name này
sẽ ra cái này
nó lấy sẽ là file name
mà mình sẽ lưu lại file đấy thôi
ông này chạy này
khi trở thành công rồi Đúng nãy giờ
không Nãy giờ chắc là bị khán nhiều thừa
thừa ảnh
cách tạo khá nhiều anh không ạ
Bây giờ mình sẽ là Cô Đắc này các bạn sẽ
thấy có 2 cái Đây Rồi
Việt cho Android
ở cái đoạn này vừa nãy mình bị sai nhưng
mà héo queo nó bị biến hình kiểu vẫn
biết hãy lưu lại chữ ra đây buồn cười
bơ cái ảnh nó ảnh nó sẽ bây giờ mình sẽ
ra
chứ không phải là thì địa là chữ ảnh
ngay đúng không ạ mình sẽ phải là
bí thư mục ảnh sẽ lại đi Ừ vậy thôi
Ê bà sẽ thu mục photo Bởi vì các bạn
nhiều không ạ mình nằm trong thư mục
photo mà không ạ ạ
ở đây anh ấy bị lỗi chứ chả nôi bởi vì
rõ ràng này để làm thiếu thông tại đâu
không ạ
ông cho hay cho nó là 100 tháng
ở đó ok chưa em mình sẽ sửa xóa ngoại đã
sửa xóa
ảnh này nhạy cảm quá nhỉ Mày không Đừng
có tố cáo kênh tôi nhé He
has three là mình sẽ nhận đến format
date ngoại
Ông mốt nào nó xóa cái bình luận kia hộ
tôi cả nhìn ngứa mắt mắt sửa à ở đây này
mình sẽ ai đi bằng cá rô ý tại ai đi ừ
Anh Ta Xưa
sau khi mình bấm vào sữa
cho tôi Tôi làm tình làng xóm cho tôi
nhìn cái
hình ảnh hàng nghìn cái ảnh cái khó chữa
xóa nhé
Xóa ngắn hơn mà không ạ ạ
Ê bà sẽ Delete này à
Em bấm vào đây sẽ xóa không ạ nhưng tạo
phải xoa này à
ở
wp
đô ride bằng đôla get ID này à
em copy cái đoạn là
em kết nối cho thử này cho nhanh à
Anh và đội đây là Delete from or Where
ID bằng id chưa xong à
Ừ mình đang chưa điều hướng gì cả về thế
là không như mình đã nói mình không nên
dùng hết đồ sớm muộn gì ạ
anh Bởi vì kéo nếu mà các bạn cốt của
vấn đây lỗi gì đó các bạn hết đồ về thì
không nhỉ Chị không nhìn thấy kịp lỗi
không ạ đi
à à
vì ai Bây giờ mình sẽ đắp liên kết kẹp
file ISO
để nó thành file update đó đi này à
Ừ nhưng mình lắm sữa đây nhưng mà bây
giờ bạn thân mà mình cần vẫn phải lấy
lại thông tin của sản phẩm để màn hình
thì ra đây Điền chưa tất cả thông tin
đối ngoại thì sẽ làm như thế nào mình sẽ
là đã quy kết lên như này một cái sẽ ra
em
có đặt này
kịch bằng mic lên à
ừ ừ
Anh bình thường đã đặt tên là mình đặt
tên Kiểu như này sao tránh bị trùng này
thế này sẽ không bị chung nữa
thế
này Ok ở đây sẽ lại Zalo này cái xô
đó là x tại lên à
chỉ có thế điện tự động Điền không ạ
Tôi thử trong mấy ông nhé
xe ô tô
ở Facebook à
à à
vụ bí kíp xuân này à
Ê mấy ông sẽ thấy có một cái thứ ở đây
nó không tự động điền được đó chính là
cái ảnh cái ảnh bản chất nó không thể tự
động điền được Cho dù kể cả các bạn có
truyền vào đường dẫn có phải đúng như
nào nữa
thì các bạn hiểu mà
Ê cái cơ chế của thằng này nó không cho
phép điều đấy nó không cho phép chọn lại
cái cũ là tính
a masterpiece Ý bạn là cái phụ là Master
your hiểu là chia bố cục của trang web ạ
Anh nhớ em Mình mạnh mình nhớ rồi Khánh
deepest đấy ạ
à à
có cây cây Nói chung ở cái vụ ảnh nó sẽ
không cho các bạn chọn lại cái hàng cũ
vì nó không coi chờ đấy Nên là thường sẽ
có kiểu như thế này thường tôi dậy sinh
viên sẽ có hai hai cái
ẩm thực thực sự đá người dùng không
ở người người dùng đôi khi và sửa người
ta đôi khi không cần sửa cái ảnh đâu nên
là
nên nên làm sẽ là theo cậu là có ông nên
hệ thứ nhất ở các mông vẫn phải liên
hiển thị lại ảnh cũ đấy điều chắc chắn
người dùng biết được có nên sửa hay
không nhưng mà khi mà người dùng chọn đề
sửa đâu ạ thì mình mới sửa còn không thì
mình phải giữ nguyên lại anh cũng phải
toàn nó phức tạp như thế cơ
em tắt cái suy nghĩ đen Ok thì bây giờ
thứ nhất là mình sẽ cân hiển thị ảnh
cũng như nào đó ngoại chị ăn dặm thôi
mình sẽ có ảnh cũ này à
các bạn cũng sợ nhất cái này và sóng đây
đây là anh cũ
Xe ô tô này
anh sẽ chiều cao cho nó tắm trăm nữa lại
ạ
Ừ anh sẽ của anh cũng như thế này vào
đây sẽ là thường là tôi sẽ thiệt cậu đã
một là đổi mới
cảm nha Trả lại
hoặc giữ lạnh cũ hiện ngay ý
Ừ ok
thì tức à Một là người dùng có thể vẫn
là chọn thêm một cái ảnh nào đó mới về
mà thay đổi ảnh như này hay là giữ ảnh
cũ không làm gì cả ngoại thì cách tốt ở
đây có chối nữa đó là mình sẽ vẫn luôn
chuyển lên cái in bút như để hai bên là
nên sẽ là photo ô trở lại tất cả ảnh cũ
tui sẽ vẫn sẽ lấy được tên của cái file
cũ
mà tại sao lại cần phải làm như thế bởi
vì mình kiểu tí mình sẽ chạy cậu update
mà ông ạ Mình sẽ update update là mình
sẽ bế cả photo nữa Thế nên là mình cần
lấy mình sẽ lấy lại luôn cái tên cũ thì
mình update vào thì nó sẽ không sao cả
đúng không ạ
Ừ nhớ đấy trong trường hợp mà người ta
không chuyền lạnh mới lên thôi không ạ Ở
đây các bạn thấy thời gian nó còn thêm
cái nữa là nó không tự động chọn vào cái
nhà sản xuất của tôi nhà xuất Tôi vừa
nãy ra để nó Apple để không sao nhưng mà
cứ là sự nhà xuất tôi tôi đội hàng ở
trên database này tự động nhé
thì mình sẽ đổi nó thành nhà sản xuất
anh ạ mã là sáu như thế này đúng ạ khi
bấm máy sưởi chị các bạn thấy thời ra nó
vẫn chị lấy phòng đầu tiên Vì mình chưa
tự động chọn nhọn thì mình sẽ chọn như
nào mình sẽ thường ngay cho một cái ít
vào đây này Mình đang chạy vòng lọc rồi
đấy nhé Đây vòng lặp đúng không ạ Mong
gặp ở đây in tất cả các chân có thể thì
mình sẽ ít ở đây ở trong vòng lặp
là nếu mà đủ lợi ích tại manufacturer ID
bằng bàn với cái
manufacturer ID này này
Ừ thì mình sẽ
có một cái selected
selected này
là là sẽ chọn đúng ạ
sự tích vào đấy auction Đấy nó như này
đó các bạn hãy nó sẽ tự động chọn đúng
không ạ
à à
Ừ đúng rồi Nếu mà không phải chuyển lên
thì mình không ăn bếp Nhưng mà mình mình
đang định là mình sẽ chỉ ghi đúng câu I
Swear thôi thay vì phải mất công ghi
tặng 2 cô gái của em ạ
anh bởi vì ở nơi thế các bạn sẽ bị đi
hai câu ghép với anh một câu fpl có cả
photo và một câu ghép của em là không ăn
Bim Photo nó không ạ thì thay vì như thế
thì mình sẽ làm theo cơ chế hết là kẹo
chị có một con fqr update bao gồm cả
photo
đây mình hiểu Ghi các bạn sẽ hiểu
sửa
đây là boot update ừ
ở
tại thì ah à thực ra nhìn lấy cái đoạn
cũ này thì hơn nhỉ
như thế này
à không nhầm nhầm nhầm nhầm vậy mà nó có
chiều rồi
anh như này thì bây giờ mình sẽ có cái
photo photo này thử các bạn để photo new
được cho phân biệt nó rõ ra à
Nó
là một cái photo đúng ạ ạ
thì
mình lấy theo Dona paz lại ra khi có va
luu rồi
à à
anh
Huy không hiểu ý bạn lắm để mình cứ thử
làm nhé sẽ xem bạn hiểu ý mình không nhá
Đây giờ sư trọng trường hợp mà mình có
photo Note này và photo không ạ thì mình
sẽ kiểm tra xem mà người dùng có chọn
ảnh 20 trong trường hợp này thì các bạn
thử xem
mình thuộc ee2 đường hợp ra để các bạn
xem lại nhé
mình sẽ bay kết thúc ngay được lên để
các bạn xem là là đây đây trong trường
hợp là sự đây trường hợp không không trợ
ảnh không ạ bấm và này
Anh
Đài đấy rồi mày nghỉ anh em lên nha và
lạy cha đã vừa nãy vẫn đang nhìn sang bố
sẽ research
đây đây trong trường hợp này các bạn sẽ
thấy alo 4 này sai là không đúng không ạ
Đấy à
ạ bây bây giờ Nếu giả sử mình chọn cái
ảnh chọn mảng bất kỳ không ạ
nó sửa đó thì các bạn thấy là Alo bằng
không này mà sai và con số lớn không ạ
Không phải con số không đúng đấy Cái
cách mình lấy ở đây mình có thể chơi trò
đó là mình kiểm tra xem lại mình thường
ấy thường là mình sẽ làm kiểm tra xem là
cái sai của cái ảnh để nó khó là không
hay không là được vì sẽ ở đây là
đầu tiên là ít
Cài foto đúng không ạ hồ sơ lưu
sai
mà lớn hơn không
Nếu bọn nó lớn hơn không Vì sao không ạ
Nếu nó lớn không thì mình sẽ đi
em có cái loạn bạn này thôi
có đoạn này đề mà lưu lại cái ảnh đúng
không ạ ô tô ở đây đổi với cái photo đấy
thì tối ưu này là xong
thì cái file name ở đây sẽ như thế này
và ngược lại thì sao thì cái file name
của mình chính là cái photo ô như thế
này
nghĩa là đang cái ảnh cũ sau đó thì câu
truy vấn của mình sẽ là
a headache này
thật đấy à bù đắp đủ ngoại xét
đây sẽ là nên bảng nên
ừ ừ
cho nên bằng lên này ờ
chỉ
còn 5 trường không ạ năm chưa
sẽ photo này
I find me me
know first rowland ai và ai đi à
À
mình quên mình quên chưa Nay đi đấy các
bạn Nếu bạn không nhớ
thì mình quên chuyện này đi trong này
mình sẽ để hai bên nên mày đi vào lưu
cho nó là
đô la ích tại
hay đi
A A Break with mikan nãy giờ mình đang
lấy lấy hơi sai khi đang lấy thằng đầu
tiên những nhiều mình quên chưa lấy theo
đôla ID phòng đôla get ID ở trên này nữa
quên đấy này ở đây mình sẽ thấy quay lại
đi vòng cho ID đây nữa
Ừ nếu mì ông chắc cũng không cho thêm
Limit một ở đây nữa cho chắc thường mà
chắc là không có chuyện ai đi chung đâu
Đi đã bị bấm vào sửa thì nó sẽ làm là gì
sẽ cảm nhận như thế này tuy nhiên đến
lợn photo này sẽ sai mà mình sẽ thay đổi
Photo nó vào đây như thế này mới đúng
này
ở trong trường hợp Hạnh bằng tay lệ tôi
test thử máy ông xem nhé
anh đã không chọn ảnh hoặc vẫn giữ ảnh
cũ nhé đổi đây là 12 này Tao cắn giờ
nhưng vẫn ngon
giá 12k anh này
về cơ cấu dự Nguyên này đi anh sữa nè
anh không thấy lỗi gì cả
cha không vấn đề gì ở bên tay bề không
có vấn đề gì Thử sáng B nasware rửa xe
phát lại lái xe mà
em không thấy có gì
tí nữa là tao cắn giờ Hà môi chuyện chưa
đẩy đưa kiếp sân lên chưa chưa sửa được
Epson họ sao
Sao lại sửa bí quyết Sơn La
Nếu như các bạn thấy là 12 12 rồi Ảnh
vẫn có thể giữ nguyên đúng không ạ Tại
sao phát nữa này
Ở đây có vẻ vẫn rồi í
các bạn chưa đang nói việc là cập nhật
theo key của code
anh kia post thì ta vẫn được nhưng mà
trong trường hợp đấy thì cái phôtôn Ê
mày nó không đúng lắm
nhà mình ý bạn là sẽ kiểu kiểm tra theo
từng ty ở đây đúng không
ý thì cái đoạn đấy à
thì mình sẽ chạy vòng sport for Women
kiểu hòa x từng đi để mình nourish ra
câu truy vấn ạ
À
thế à Các bạn hiểu ý mình cái đoạn vừa
rồi không ạ Cái cái đoạn này đó là nếu
mà file file ảnh chuyển lên thì mình sẽ
cấp cập nhật không ạ Rồi là không truyền
lên cái ảnh nào thì nó sẽ như thế này à
có bao giờ sự là mình sẽ truyền phải lên
như thế này
Ừ chị ông kia là false
A7 nhiêu câu
SQL để mà chen giacco spo2 à
77 nhiêu câu I Swear để update bấy nhiêu
cái trường đó nếu mà update bấy nhiêu
lần thì thôi Không khuyên mấy ông chơi
trò này em nhé Không phải truyền bao
nhiêu lên rồi ông update bấy nhiêu đâu
Đúng
Em học việc là định chân risaco Apple
thì nó hơi bị hơn
à à
Ừ nhưng mà thứ là cái nhưng mà các bạn
vừa nói nó sẽ còn bị lỗ hổng đấy
Ừ nó bị lỗ hổng về bảo mật nghĩa là nếu
thế thì có người dùng mà sửa cái nên của
cái trong post các bạn mà các bạn chưa
Violet rồi ạ ạ Các bạn chuyển lên sửa
sửa những cái nó không mình không quy
ước ở đây thì nó nguy hiểm
anh ấn vào này không thấy lỗi gì cả em
mình sẽ thử à
Ô thế Mình chỉ cần quay lại đây rồi tài
lạnh Trang là được chúng gọi thấy ảnh
thay đổi tới ủng hộ đúng không ạ tớ ra
mình đã cập nhật lại ảnh thì thôi
Ai Cập nhật hàng rồi
Ừ anh lỗi
hình ảnh đưa lạ
ở nhà ở vừa nãy mình đúng rồi Vừa nãy
mình lỡ nhảy sang file xap Thành bị bị
pet một cái
Sau
đó các bạn vừa thấy đầy đủ see you d
Nó là liên kết đến hai bạn nóng bọn nó
sẽ có thêm câu truy vấn đề em ạ lấy lên
lấy từ cái bản khác nữa đúng ạ ạ à quên
quên quên Còn bây giờ nốt nốt nốt Kỳ nữa
đó là ừ ừ
nhà mình cần in ra được cả nhà tên nhà
sản xuất này
tên nhà sản xuất
ở đây trả lại thì các bạn sẽ thấy là ở
trong bảng bản này khi chỉ có ma đâu
phước trời đi thôi không có tên nhà sản
xuất không ạ cho mình là tên của gì mình
sẽ lại cho hay thôi mình sẽ cho ở đây là
bị cho Model fossil
on cô đất chấm mà nó Future lại đi bằng
Mortal chở mai đi này không ạ Và đây
nhưng mà khi ở các bạn chạy như này nó
sẽ lỗi một cái
Ừ Thế xem tại xã lỗi nhé các câu truy
vấn lại mình có gì sai
Vì sao phong thấp trói
các câu truy vấn này cũng nghĩ có gì sai
à
ở Tây Du Ký
Ừ
nếu mà nó chạy báo lỗi Như CIA tất cả
câu truy vấn sai đấy
à à thiếu chữ s
à à
thế này các bạn sẽ thấy là cái cái khi
mà chạy cái này xong thì cái nêm này của
mình nó bị ghi đè lên bởi nêm cổ thằng
montefeltro và IDE thế tất cả những cái
thằng thằng nó bị do đằng sau Nó sẽ ghi
đè lên hàng nói trước ngày ra là cách
tốt của mình thôi Làm ở đây đó là mình
sẽ thường hay khi forests chấm sao là
lấy tất cả sự tất cả cột từ bảng cố lắp
ạ sau đó thì mình sẽ lấy thêm những cái
cột mình cần lấy thôi từ bảng này và
mình sẽ đổi tên nó Nó làm an ở for Touch
ID mà nêm như này xa lạ và đây sẽ là mày
Future lên như thế này đó thì nó sẽ ổn
đó các bạn thấy không
ở đây đây đây là về cơ bản của toàn bộ
về CRD để mà
ep3 cậu liên kết 23
sẽ cho bạn thấy ở thật ra mình cũng nhắc
đi nhắc lại về máy cày kiểu xem thêm sữa
Xóa các thư cũng khá nhiều đúng không ạ
cần nhở cũng bộ ôn tập nữa
Ừ nhưng mà nói chung à
Ừ thế này cũng tương đối rồi đấy ạ là
mình đã làm được tính năng ở bên A
ở
bên admin như này thì các bạn sẽ chỉ cần
ạ
ở gần nhà làm lại đống này đã gần nửa
cái nó khán
ở bên emminh rồi về với lại bên admin
thực ra mình cũng không yêu cầu nhiều
tính năng nhắn
em muốn sữa kích cỡ của ảnh khi viết in
like thì chị được internal vết kiểu
Exciter hồi đôi khi là nó còn lưu cách
xét như là đôi khi ở các bạn sẽ bị
phải nó bị cách cái các bạn phải xóa
cách đi mới sửa lỗi nhé á
Các bạn nhớ mạng có phần có tiện ích của
mình từ ly cách này các bạn tải về các
bạn thử Xóa đi biết đâu chạy được
Em ở chỗ nào Buổi sau của mình thì mình
sẽ dạy các bạn về bên giao diện với
khách hàng để hiển thị ra toàn bộ sản
phẩm xong rồi các thứ nó ngoại phải kết
hợp với Phương Trang đã tìm kiếm nữa
không ạ
300 đón một thì không có tính năng
nghiệp tất cả toán một thì về cơ bản nó
sẽ chỉ có tương đồng như này thôi nó
thêm sửa xóa tất cả các thứ
Ừ ông kia ở nói cái gì Cái thống kê cơ à
Thôi tôi sẽ đồ ăn một thì tôi sẽ không
dậy xong mấy ông mấy cái điều đấy còn
nếu mấy ông vẫn muốn làm thì tôi vẫn cho
phép nhưng mà tôi sẽ chỉ dạy toàn bộ như
cái có bạn những cơ thể ông ạ yên tâm
còn thêm những cái tính năng cũng có tí
sức tạp nữa giống như tôi nói phức tạp
nhất của bên bán hàng so với bên tin tức
mà chính là cái giỏ hàng không ạ thì thì
tôi sẽ dạy người không
ô thưa cải cái một tối đang dạy này thì
các bạn cũng ôm sang bên A tin tức được
mà nó nhọn
à
Tôi đang dậy mấy cái này thì mấy ông sẽ
thấy là cho các nhà sản xuất này bạn
chất nó là tắt Dạ hoặc sản phẩm nó sẽ là
bài đăng tin tức trở lại đúng không ạ
Đấy
3000 có phân quyền gì cả sự phân quyền
các bạn chạy thẳng vào trong cốc thôi
làm chứ ạ Ai ra được gì đó Cái về bài
toán về ạ quyền hay các thứ đấy thì nó
liên quan đăng nhập thì mình sẽ hướng
dẫn các bạn phải đăng nhập nữa ở trung
hòa những những buổi sắp tới nhé mình sẽ
dạy về nhất là thí sinh này họ đăng nhập
này buổi sau đây sẽ là giao diện với
khách hàng này không ạ nghĩa trang chủ
này rồi bấm vào xem cụ thể hoặc trang
chủ này xem cụ thể sản phẩm sản chưa chữ
làm nhiệm vụ bên giỏ hàng vội mà mình sẽ
tìm hiểu về season đi qua đăng nhập
trước đã đăng nhập này đăng ký rồi ra
đăng ký đơn giản hãy đăng ký nó bạn chất
nó Insert thôi mà nóng lạnh mình dậy các
bạn để đăng nhập
ạ sau đó thì mình sẽ dạy các bạn với
Cookie để mà kiểu lưu lại khi năng lưu
lại trạng thái đăng nhập bằng gì đó là
xinh đăng nhập đúng không ạ
điều lạ đăng nhập
sau đó thì mình mới dậy các bạn về giỏ
hàng
đúng rồi người ta thường ai dùng
localstorage hoa cà thậm chí đưa đại
trong tay giống như hôm trước các bạn
nói nhưng mà mình dậy các bạn thì ghi
lại trong xin thôi Đợi thì
đợi tí mình xử lý con chó Đã à
thế hả bạn kia bảo à
cô bạn kia vợ làm sao nhiều hướng là như
nào nhỉ Mình chưa hiểu ý bạn lắm
số
trang điều hướng ở như này
em trả mày nuôi cá thử à
Ừ đúng đúng rồi season me mình hôm trước
mình tự nói đấy đó là đó là season mình
mình không nói giờ còn lưu giỏ hàng
trong chất sừng này nó sẽ ra cái cậu nó
là cậu cái tiện nhất hay các thứ mà mình
dạy các bạn làm việc lưu lại trong sự
gìn thấy để các bạn với qua khái niệm về
màn và biết qua khái niệm chưa dừng thôi
rồi cay thường là nhiều nhiều nơi bây
giờ sẽ rượu trông DB nhưng mà nóng sẽ bị
rát nó sẽ bị rát dp không ạ
em không có họ không có khóa là của mình
dạy về api cả Chắc mình sẽ chỉ để mô các
bạn api những cái buổi lại like cốc thôi
Bởi vì à
ở vỉa kiểu đến đến cả bên rare những gì
dạy các bạn cơ bản chứ không dạy các bạn
chân xấu lắm
âm thanh tra xuân sang thì hôm trước họp
rồi nữa không ạ oke này còn gì nữa nhỉ
họ hàng này nọ hàng ở đây sẽ là là thêm
sửa thêm thêm sản phẩm xóa xóa gọi hàng
các thứ thứ sau đó còn Xem giỏ hàng
không ạ thêm sản phẩm vào giỏ hàng này
cập nhật số lượng này
Xóa gọi hàng vào Xem giỏ hàng
này kiểu như thế
ạ sau đó thì các bạn cái cuối cùng là
xem hóa đơn và hóa đơn chi tiết đã
đó đó là đầy đủ những cách tính năng cơ
bản nhất của cái trang web bán hàng Thì
mình sẽ dạy các bạn để bọn mình sẽ dạy
các bạn tất cả những cái này con các bạn
muốn kiểu làm hư cậu là làm thêm tính
năng nữa thì các bạn hãy hỏi mà mình sẽ
cân nhắc Nếu mà có nhiều bạn cũng hỏi
thì mình sẽ để để mua qua thứ hòa mình
sẽ chị hưởng qua
khoa học cơ bản thế cho là bạn chưa đọc
mua tạm rồi này trở khi mình sẽ thấy ghi
lại phần mô tại sao cái cày danh sách
này cái cái khóa học cơ bản này chỉ để
cho các bạn hiểu qua tương đối thể lập
trình web nó là như nào nó lại nó nó là
như thế nào thôi làm được rõ thuần như
thế nào chứ để mà đi đi thực tập 2 để đi
làm thì có bạn sẽ chưa chưa đủ kiến thức
cũng như là
em vừa chưa đủ kiến thức này vừa phải
họp lại thêm nhiều thứ nữa với thực tế
nó cũng sẽ phát ra khá nhiều
À thỉnh cái cái này cần điều thì cho các
bạn biết thế nào lập trình này mà cũng
như là
xem các bạn có phù hợp với ngay nhé
không thì các bạn làm xong mà các bạn
thấy dễ quá rồi không đến nỗi như các
bạn thấy ổn và các bạn xem được thì các
bạn sẽ nên cần học thêm khóa nâng cao
sau của mình để mà cũng tra cũng chỉ mất
ba bốn tháng nữa thôi để mà các bạn với
hiểu biết thực tế nhất
đi hát kẹo thực tế nó sẽ cậu cốt như thế
nào đúng không ạ Mình sẽ dụng Facebook
như thế nào mô hình rồi là như thế nào
xử lý bài toán chuyên sâu nói như thế
nào Vân Vân Vân đó ngoại để các bạn khi
đi ra với các bạn sẽ đi làm được luôn
không cần phải cần như ở không cần phải
mất thời gian thực tập nữa Cái đấy mình
phải này được vì các bạn thể làm được
việc luôn
ừ ừ
A và nâng cao về nội trẻ 23 tháng các
thứ thôi
nhưng mà
Ừ nó cũng giống như cái đồ án này sau 23
tháng các bạn sẽ phải có một cái sẵn
phẩm đoán là các bạn sẽ cũng áp lực phết
Nói chung là các bạn theo từ giờ thì mà
theo đến cuối cứ cho nó 6 tháng nữa
không ạ Có thể hơn một tí
cho 7 tháng đi cho giải
Ừ thì 7 tháng nữa là các bạn sẽ hoàn
toàn là đi làm được ngon Nếu thực sự các
bạn theo được từ đầu đến cuối
ảnh của khóa của mình
đó là đương nhiên là đền cái khóa nâng
cao thì như các bạn sẽ vừa học vừa hơi
bị chặn bật một tí hóa cơ bản này mình
còn cầm tay chỉ lỗi được yêu kiểu từng
bước từng bước các bạn cũng sẽ hiểu từng
bước hành khóa nâng cao thì mình cũng
cũng thức cũng vẫn sẽ dậy như này nhưng
mà các bạn sẽ phải tự tìm hiểu cũng cũng
nhiều đúng hạn vì mình không phải dạy
hết được vì cái nó nâng cao nó rất nhiều
cái mình không thể dạy hết được vì chỉ
dẫn cách bao quát thôi thì
Ừ đúng rồi đã có thể đi thực tập Vượt
Lụa đi làm được luôn chứ không phải là
hai tháng thực tập 2 3 4 hãng được tập
nữa đúng không ạ Cái đấy mình khẳng định
được vì vì cái họ nâng cao mình định dậy
thì nó sẽ là kiểu các bạn sẽ ghi hậu qua
về cả mày mô hình có thứ
ở gần như xong khóa nâng cao của mình
các bạn hệ của chén là các bạn có 1 hoặc
2 năm kinh nghiệm vẫn có thể được cái
đấy thì mình mình nghĩ à Bởi vì bản chất
và các bạn sau hóa nâng cao thì các bạn
sẽ phải làm thêm có đồ ăn nữa thì nhanh
bằng các bạn làm hai cái đồ án rồi thì
nha bằng 15 thí nghiệm rồi
ừ ừ
e100 nếu mà mình dậy cốt thuật thì mình
sẽ chỉ để mô qua mình mình thỉnh thoảng
mình sẽ
chị sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn về khách khùng
mà nóng lạnh chỉ các bạn về nghị cần đỗ
hỏng cái thứ
có cái in Hôm trước mình gọi để mua các
bạn về Acquy Arsenal không ạ
anh vào mấy hôm nữa thì
mấy hôm nữa Chắc là hôm sau cũng được
Hôm sau về cái vụ trang chủ của khách
hàng có tìm kiếm đã gặp phân trang mình
sẽ dạy các bạn về xs nữa để các bạn hình
dung thêm về cái vụ nó thì nguy hiểm như
nào ở trên cái đón một các bạn khi mà
các bạn cốt thuần cơ mà không kiểm tra
người dùng nhập thì nó sẽ đầy lỗ hộp
nhưng về đến đồ án 2 thì cần đưa nó sẽ
nó là Facebook nó hỗ trợ các bạn vì mình
cái lỗ hổng rồi các bạn sẽ gần như không
vừa phải quan tâm đấy nữa có phải chỉ
quan tâm đến những cái về lôgic thôi
chi tiết
Xin
chào bạn bạn mới biết đến kênh của mình
hơi muộn thế cơ à mới biết đến kênh của
mình mà đã xem cái video này rồi là nó
lại hơi say quá quay lại video đổi tiền
xem bạn ạ
ừ ừ
khi được dùng computer không
anh
đi bạn hả
Ý bạn là scf được nhưng không dây bạn
kia hỏi hay là như này thật ra các bạn
vẫn được dùng có bao giờ cái thứ
cái đấy nó là trình biên dịch cho họ
không ảnh hưởng gì cả
từ nãy giờ đầy đủ kiến thức mình dậy rồi
nha Bây giờ mình đang chờ được câu hỏi
thôi đúng ạ Hôm nay thì mình Khâm định
chia sẻ thêm cái gì sợ hơi quá tải các
bạn ấy thì mình hứa buổi sau vậy nhá
buổi sau mình sẽ chia sẻ có thời gian
thêm mình sẽ chia sẻ một tí hay khủng
nếu như bạn kia bảo nó không ạ xss lại
avantech sinh con Nếu mà có thêm thời
gian nữa thì mình sẽ tranh thủ chữa bài
câu ashwell hôm trước nữa nợ hơi lâu rồi
thì các bạn còn hỏi gì không ạ
à à con boss của của pp này thì thoải
mái thôi
thì các bạn sẽ trải Lên thư viện Hãy
dùng có boso để máy chạy cốt được không
sao
anh có xem được không Ý bạn là sao nhỉ
Thế các bạn thì à
cách dùng dùng nốt hết dùng cái ngôn ngữ
Bắc em thì cần đưa nó sẽ bị mã hóa kiểu
khó đau quá à
cô bạn kia hỏi mình hỏi đây
ngồi nhiều thì mình thì ngồi mình cũng
thấy biển đệm nữa bởi vì mình gây Nếu
mình ngồi không thì con nhận cũng bị đau
mông Đấy
Ừ đúng rồi bây giờ cũng có nhiều ai ai
được các bạn lên gõ lên gõ cậu gọi mô tả
đấy nó sẽ sinh ra được cả trang web hoặc
à vẽ vẽ bừa gì đó nó sinh ra được trang
web
không ạ
khi xem màn đấy vẫn chỉ ở giao diện thôi
chi tiết
Ừ Ok bạn chỗ mà bây giờ cũng muộn rồi
khi cha đẻ có gì các bạn thắc mắc thì cứ
bình luận sau nhé mình sẽ trả lời sau
ở tạm nghỉ Hôm nay nhé Chào bạn
thế Element node.js thì có xem được khóa
này không Ừ thế cũng được Nhưng mà như
hôm trước tôi nói cả Mệt mấy ông nữa mon
nộp đoán cho tôi không không đi nộp bằng
ngôn ngữ khác thì tôi dậy là thì chắc
chị chấm mong muốn gửi thế thôi à
à À còn con ông làm bằng ngôn ngữ lập
trình nào ông xem khóa của tôi thì cũng
biết thêm được thêm kiến thức mới mà
không thưa đâu nóng lạnh
Xin chào bạn nhé
ừ ừ